now the constant Democratic struggles I
guess is why Oh
Duval Patrick Michael Bloomberg are
making the last stitch bids for the
desperate Democratic Party because they
know the Trump is on the path to victory
by the way Michael Bloomberg's campaign
manager just flat-out admitted it take a
look and if you look at the polls and
people can't focus on this the general
election is in six states that's it
right it's in Wisconsin Michigan
Pennsylvania North Carolina Florida and
Arizona that's the whole general
election and right now Donald Trump is
winning he is winning that election is
very tough for people who don't live in
New York or California to understand
that but that is what's happening in
three hundred and forty three days you
we the American people you get the final
say wouldn't it be cool to shock the
world again
just shock the mob and the media how
much how great would it be on election
night when they have to say
Donald Trump has reelected 45th
President of the United States of
America gee they probably crack under
the pressure
by the way joining us now with reaction
former White House press secretary Fox
News contributor Sarah Sanders 34.5 and
34% african-american community six
separate polls the lowest one had the
president had doubled the number he had
in 2016 if that load number holds to me
my analysis that would mean game over
it's done president has served the
minority communities better than the
eight years of a Biden Obama record low
unemployment for african-americans
asian-americans Hispanic Americans women
in the workplace youth unemployment
I guess the narrative that Republicans
are racist sexist homophobic is not true
is it
not at all certainly not this president
I'm just glad to see that there's
finally I never thought I would say this
Shawn but I finally think that one of
the Democrats has figured it out Michael
Bloomberg's campaign manager actually
got something right and admitted it
Donald Trump is winning and all of
America is winning and that's why his
numbers
continue to go up it's just amazing to
see that somebody from their side is
actually admitting it and talking about
it publicly and I think if those numbers
stay holed where they are even as a
baseline it's not just game over but it
is a landslide victory for this
president and I think America I see I
think the plan is is that the Obama I
don't know supporters that they have I
guess their own little institution those
supporters of his they seem to be
coalescing around of all Patrick and I
see and I say that for Lottery's David
Axelrod support Obama's timed comments
about their to extreme now as more
recent comments do you believe that they
are now desperately trying to support
him in the last-minute push here I think
they're desperately trying to find
somebody who can actually run a real
campaign so far everything we've seen
out of the Democrat field does nothing
but make every Republican in this
country extremely happy because it's
clear that Donald Trump is going to win
re-election anybody who is painfully set
and watched each of these Democratic
debates knows that Joe Biden is an
incredibly weak candidate and he's their
frontrunner he's tied up in corruption
scandal after scandal and he still
considered the front-runner and he's a
terrible candidate and everybody knows
that including former President Obama
who had him as his vice president for
eight years I mean it is a it's a sad
day when you can't get that guy to help
support you are you making pies for
Thanksgiving because I remember the mob
and the media doubted you made pies and
you actually made them some and they
didn't deserve it except maybe if you
actually just accidentally hitting him
kidding never would have done that but
I'm definitely making more pies I'm
hosting Thanksgiving at my house this
year shot all I'll be sure to tweet a
few of those out for you you live in the
greatest country God gave man they have
the greatest military defending us and
thank you and I wish you and your family
your dad a Happy Thanksgiving and your
mom thank you we have great great lots
of great things to be thankful for happy
Thanksgiving to you too happy
Thanksgiving